you might think of fake images as a
modern curse of social media from the
supposed landing of a plane in a Hong
Kong typhoon to the ubiquitous shark
attributed to every flooded city but
pictures have been faked for centuries
and two of the most famous have just
sold for more than 20,000 pounds the
Cottingley fairies were famously
photographed in 1917 by 16 year-old
Elsie Wright and her nine-year-old
cousin Frances Griffiths my
grandfather's lund initially he'd be
purchased at some time in the past the
pictures were taken at the bottom of a
garden or in Cottingley in West
Yorkshire using Elsie's father's camera
colored paper and pins
despite the distinct lack of fairies
there now people are still fascinated
they make it a bit of a day out come to
Katya and try and see where the pictures
were taken of the fairies and they've
obviously learnt as well through school
and probably the parents and reading
books what's gone on in Cottingley and
they'd like to see the original place
where it was the pictures became famous
because Sherlock Holmes creator Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle published them anyone
can cut out fake fairies but in his
defense this was 1920 around this time
an awful lot of people had lost people
in the First World War
and that gave a huge amount of impetus
to spiritualism because people didn't
want to think that their lost ones were
lost forever or that they could never
speak to them again
the girls took more pictures at conan
doyle's request and their cameras and
now in Bradford's science and Media
Museum it's an enduring appeal I think
there are still people lots of people
who not just want to believe in fairies
because that's too simple but actually
want to believe in something else
so beyond what they know and having
images of those created by children a
hundred years ago there's something
really quite special about that so
special that Cottingley has named
streets after fairies and even put them
on the village green the girls finally
owned up in the 1980s there were no
fairies just people who wanted to
believe in them Jared sub Sky News
Cottingley